tell us about the cobra thing you've
just chaired do you believe at this
moment that a full scale of in the
invasion of ukraine is underway well let
me let me tell you what uh what's been
going on so we've just uh
had a cobra meeting about the the
situation in
ukraine particularly in
in the donbass region where
plainly
president putin has now
violated ukrainian sovereignty he's sent
troops in he's broken into national law
he's repudiated the minsk agreements and
torn up the the understanding it uh from
budapest in 1994 that uh
ukraine's uh territory integrity would
be respected you know he's completely
torn up uh international law
we will immediately institute a package
of economic sanctions which i think is
people would expect targeted not just
identities in
in donbass in new gangster and donetsk
but uh in russia itself targeting uh
russian uh economic interests as hard as
we can uh and uh we will we will be i'll
be sending out a bit later on in the
house comments uh what we
are going to do
this is i should stress just the first
barrage of uk uh economic sanctions
against uh against russia
because we expect i'm afraid that uh
there is more russian
irrational behavior to come and uh
the sad thing is that at every turn in
this crisis the uk's pessimistic
predictions have been vindicated we said
that there would be false flag
operations and there have been false
flag operations we said that there would
be uh provocations in uh in the donbass
and that's exactly what uh we're now
seeing
and i'm afraid all the evidence is that
president putin is indeed bent as you uh
said just now on a full-scale invasion
of ukraine
and the uh overrunning the subjugation
of a independent sovereign european
country and i think that let's be
absolutely clear i think that would be
absolutely catastrophic
there will of course be
uh
pressure for continued conversation for
negotiations and and that's right
there's whilst there's still a
discussion to be had of course a
discussion uh should be had and the uk
will be engaged actively in diplomacy at
all levels to uh to try to find a way
forward other than uh through uh the
violence that president putin seems to
be proposing but i i just want everybody
to be in in no doubt that if
vladimir putin continues down this track
of a violence of aggression
of a full-scale invasion of encircling
kiev itself which is what he seems to be
proposing to do capturing of the
ukrainian capital it is absolutely vital
that that effort that
that
conquest of another european country
should not succeed and that uh putin
should fail and that is what uh we will
be exerting ourselves to uh ensuring is
is the outcome can you tell us a bit
about what sanctions you're going to
bring in today on russian families and
businesses in the uk and why do you
think they're going to be effective
given that the threat of sanctions
didn't appear to be very effective what
is what is the reason for ratcheting
them up in this way some now and some
later so i'll explain later on in the
house what we're going to to do but i
want to and so probably right to wait
till then to to set out the full the
full package
but the intention is not just to hit the
entities within uh lugansk and and
donetsk uh but but uh but those
and those russian economic interests
that have been uh supporting uh russia's
uh russia's war machine everything that
uh is being done uh to support the
russian uh activities in that area
they will hit russia very hard and there
is a lot more that we are
going to do in the event of an invasion
and
be in no doubt that if if russia is
prevented russian companies prevented
from raising uh capital on uh uk
financial markets if we unpeel the
facade of russian ownership of of
companies of property uh it will start
to hurt
you want to do this on concert with
other western countries with the us and
other european countries do you think
that russian banks do you think that the
nordstream pipeline should be involved
from the start i think one of the most
important things we've got to understand
looking back at
and the the invasion
of crimea the the annexation of of
crimea and what happened
back then in eastern ukraine
we've got to recognize that we were not
uh tough enough and
in the end we we didn't do enough
as europeans
to wean ourselves
off
russian hydrocarbons off russian oil and
gas and uh to except to certain extent
now uh the the vagaries of the price in
gas the spikes in in gas prices to which
uh european economies are are so
vulnerable is a consequence of of that
failure uh to move away from uh that
dependency that's what we've got to do
now we've got to make sure uh that we we
cut the umbilicus we we snip the the
drip feed into
our our bloodstream from nordstrom
prime minister what did you make of
vladimir putin's address last night
saying that ukraine had no right to be a
state you talked about his irrational
behavior do you think some western
leaders were naive to think that
diplomacy could work i think that the uk
has spotted this a long way out and i
don't know whether you read his 5 000
word essay on
on the history of ukraine and and it's
uh he basically makes the same point and
he made it many months ago that he
believes that uh that ukraine has no
real uh
right to exist as a as a sovereign
independent country but that goes
against everything uh that
we
struggled to achieve at the end of the
cold war it goes against the aspirations
of the ukrainian people and i think the
most difficult thing now for vladimir
putin in in prosecuting this war
he will come up against something that i
think will be very hard for him to beat
and that is the ukrainian sense of
national pride and their determination
to defend their country and uh to fight
for it i think that the tragedy of the
present situation is that president
putin has surrounded himself with
like-minded advisors who tell him
that ukraine is uh is is not a proper
country and i think that he's going to
find that he has gravely miscalculated
you talked to president zielenski last
night about sending defensive more
defensive weaponry to ukraine are we
going to do that and could it at some
point become offensive weaponry i think
it's very important that we stay within
uh our obligations to uh to to the
ukrainians and we're going to do that
we're going to keep uh helping them in
economically supporting them in the way
that we have as supporting the ukrainian
uh
economy but also giving them a lethal
but defensive uh assistance and i think
i believe that uh the british people
will uh support the uk government in
doing that i think that they have a
right uh to defend their country and and
the uk will help them do that so we'll
send them send them more we're looking
at we're looking at what we can do what
more we can do to help as you know we've
we've trained about 22 000 members of
the uk of the ukrainian uh arms armed
forces uh and also given them some uh
some anti-tank weaponry and some other
kit but we'll look at what more we can
do but this in this we are joined i
should say by like-minded allies uh the
americans of poles lithuanians and
others prime minister you talked about
cutting the cord of russian oil and gas
to a lot of families in the uk worried
about energy bills they're worried this
is going to have an even greater impact
what can you say to reassure them about
that don't forget that in the uk
we've been able to reduce our dependency
on on russian gas very substantially
only three percent of our gas supplies
now come from from russia uh what we
want to do is make sure that we uh give
the the necessary licenses for instance
for uh for uk uh reserves of gas as we
make the transition to uh to to a low
carbon future but also uh go forward
with a uh a short medium and long-term
plan for energy in this country uh
whereby we we
massively accelerate our our renewables
campaign uh but also deliver more
nuclear as fast as as fast as we can the
faster this country can be uh more
self-reliant on uh our own energy uh the
the more prosperous we will be but also
of course
the more
more sustainable our energy prices will
be and that will benefit the uk consumer
thank you thank you thank you